rugs is not the only raider involved in
a car accident around this time last
year raiders defensive back damon arnett
was in a hit-and-run crash now in that
crash the victim survived is now suing
the football player this crash happened
on bermuda road and saint rose parkway
right where the raiders training and
practice facility is madison kimbrough
live in that area with details as well
as what residents have to say about
speeding there madison
yeah luckily no one died in the crash
that happened with our net back in
october of 2020 but as you can see with
recent happenings of rugs and speeding
across the valley it has become a major
problem and residents are concerned
right away it's become a little bit of a
race track when i come off the street
you know obviously i gotta i gotta wait
for the cars to pass and they're just
they're flying scott mart shares his
observations as he drives to work daily
right across from the raiders training
facility just last october raiders
defensive back damon arnett was involved
in a hit and run crash here on bermuda
road and saint rose parkway in that
exact area while the woman he hit
survived she is now suing the football
player for medical compensation court
documents reveal that arnett was late to
a meeting at the raiders headquarters
and was speeding when quote the wheels
on his vehicle skidded and he lost
control crashing into a woman's car on
the driver's side arnett left the scene
of the crash but was later located and
confronted at raiders headquarters when
he admitted to causing the accident
retired henderson police officer ryan
brightwell says speeding in this area is
so common i've seen
cars trucks a lot of cars leaving the
practice facility at high rates of speed
after traffic or after practice
breitwell says when it comes to athletes
they need to be held accountable just
like everybody else it's shocking when
you think about it because somebody
that's making four million dollars a
year like he was
has all the resources in the world to
not have this happen
the woman arnett hitt suffered several
reported injuries and is now suing the
football player for over a hundred
thousand dollars to pay for her medical
bills and additional damages reporting
live madison kimbrough live local now